well uh in the last few moments grant
shapps
has in fact tweeted to
explain what is on the english
list when it comes to green countries
this is what he says you can see the
tweet there we're adding malta
to the government green list we're also
adding madeira the baleric islands
several uk overseas territories and
caribbean islands including barbados to
the green list and green watch list
israel and jerusalem are also added to
the green watch list he goes on to say
six countries including tunisia
and haiti will be put on the red list
all these changes of course coming into
effect
from wednesday the 30th of june at 4 00
a.m now he also
says and this also was uh uh strongly
anticipated thanks to our successful
vaccination program our intention
is that later in the summer no date as
yet
uk residents who are fully vaccinated uh
will not
have to isolate when traveling from
amber list
countries we will set out further
details
next month our political correspondent
joe pike has dashed into the studio
he's seen that tweets along with the
rest of us so as
expected joe this list uh coming uh
strangely after northern ireland and and
scotland uh sent out their lists
yeah and good news that the green list
is growing but particularly
particularly i think this new green
watch list now it was originally
promised there would be a watch list a
sort of
a danger zone for countries in the
greenness that they could be relegated
to amber grant chaps making it clear
that madeira the balearics and the
caribbean islands
mentioned are on that green watch list
and
israel and jerusalem which is already on
the green list where we know
cases are rising even though the israeli
vaccine role has been so successful are
also
on the green watch list what this
suggests i suppose is that yes you can
travel to these places but don't be
surprised if we do have a portugal-like
situation
three weeks ago portugal without really
any warning at all was moved
green to amber and that caused a lot of
problems for holidaymakers and
the sector so i suppose you should book
but with
awareness with caution knowing that
maybe there could be
trouble ahead i'm sure many in the
travel industry will see this as
progress because in particular the
balearics and
caribbean islands are common summer
holiday destinations that is good for an
industry
that has really been struggling and
angry furious over
uh recent weeks we've got the clarity on
the watch list but this big unknown
uh on the date when people who've had
two jabs will be able to travel with
fewer restrictions tweet says later in
the summer and then there's a little
sunshine emoji
but no date but the summer has summer
has officially started
the summer solstice was uh on sunday
summer holidays are perhaps what the
government are really thinking about
because we know that's when a lot of
money will be spent and that's what
when a lot of voters especially those
with families will want
to travel i think we they'll be sort of
increasing
calls for more clarity he does say later
this month boris johnson
and every cabinet minister this week has
been really positive
about how the success of the uk's
vaccine program will allow
more international travel but of course
labor argue
look are we creating a two-tier system
older people like yourself jonathan
who've had two jabs are in a better
position than somebody who's in their
late teens or early 20s
and has had none or won and therefore
why younger people
who've really suffered in this pandemic
people who've maybe just left school or
uni
why are they more restricted when others
can go and have a nice holiday yeah um
the other issue of course is there's
there's an irony joe here isn't there
that um
we're opening things up and adding more
countries to that green list just as
angela merkel starts saying well we
don't want you to come yeah and
what we don't know is whether there will
be much sort of unanimity across
europe angela merkel and emmanuel macron
have both suggested there should be a
europe-wide
strategy for dealing with brits coming
to their countries
but remember the spanish the greek
economies are so reliant on british
holidaymakers germany's
are far less so i'd argue and therefore
would they want to suddenly block off
this key
income stream at a such a critical point
when
a second significant summer of no
british investment could really
hit local communities uh very badly it's
unclear what will
happen in europe but of course there is
a good point boris johnson and grant
chaps
can release the restrictions all they
like but if angela merkel and co put
more restrictions up holidays may not be
that possible no okay and when will the
list be reviewed just quickly
three weeks time